All right, we're now gonna take a look at groom shadowing and lighting as there's a few settings on our groom
That can affect how the groom is going to react to environment lighting and things like that. So
here is
Some examples of the various settings that you will actually find here
So if we pop over here to our groom
I'm talking about these settings that we're gonna find right here as well as our hair shadow density
It's a little bit easier to show you here in this PowerPoint. So first off no settings
This is gonna be our default that you see and that is also going to include voxel eyes
voxel eyes enables strand voxel ization for casting
Environment occlusion this basically allows us to have the hair look like it's getting some occlusion from things that are around it
Enabling use a stable raster ization will ensure the hair does not alias
When enabled groups of hair might appear thicker and isolated hair should remain thin
So this is a great way if you have
Different types of hair like maybe you have some smaller clumps or bigger clumps or something like that to help things not alias
So bad now scatter scene lighting but enabled that this will
light the hair with the scene color and is used for
short hair or peach fuzz to help kind of bring light from the surrounding surface like the skin to
Illuminate and this particular example, it doesn't make a lot of sense because this is very long hair
But if we were doing something like beard hair or some peach fuzz or maybe some really light arm hair
This would be a better setting to have enabled as it would make things more pronounced
And then last we have what the hair would look like with everything enabled now
This is just for demonstration purposes
You may or may not need to enable all these settings depending on your light setup and what you're trying to accomplish with your
groom lighting it's just to
Show you that there are some things that you can do to adjust the lighting for your groom based on
What your groom is trying to accomplish?